Would you say that attack on Titan is carrying your 20, 21 so far? Yeah, dude,
every episode I'm getting hyped for, she just, you know,
be appreciative of the fact that we're even getting a tack on time, right?
Like in the midst of a pandemic. Huh? I mean,
the fact is that attack on Titan it's it could be carrying any here because I
don't think that anything can live up to what attack and tightened season four
is giving us right now.
And I say this in the midst of what I would want the strongest seasons we've
ever had. I would argue that this is the front,
this is a contender for one of the strongest seasons in the history of
anime. That is a big statement,
but like it's so stacked in every
single genre and every single kind of every single category you
can think of that.
I can't think of a single person who can't find at least two or three shows that
there'll be watching the season. And then on top of that,
you have the classic being made. That is attack one time. Why would you, I,
you know, if I was an anime studio and I found out when talking type was airing,
I'd be like, you know what? Just hold on. Don't don't let's wait,
like on YouTube, you know, if you upload a video,
we had like Shane Dawson dropped a documentary. It was like, just, don't just,
don't like movie companies being like, wait, Avengers in cinemas right now,
at least at the same time as Avengers, because they're like, no,
one's going to watch it. Like almost I would have been like,
just hold off because the attack on Titans going to carry,
like even if I only get to watch it once a week,
it's going to be in my mind the whole week.
So let's just hold off and give me a bang of next season. But now they, all,
everyone was like, let's all come out right now.
Let's let's all have all our bangers right now with this one season.
Cause like the amount of like,
we we've had a few seasons previously with some season twos here and there,
but it seems like every season too,
or like sequel the season is a banger. Yeah.
Because like his beast is airing right now. Right. Okay. So do not know any,
no one is talking about it. Yeah,
because that attack on Titan is the only thing. Okay. Okay.
So we got B stars too. We got, gotta be amazing. We've got promise.
We've got promise. Never lapsed. No one promise Netherland came out.
It was massive. He was the only one spoke about. Yeah. Um,
we got lock horizon three. Quintz two quintessential quintuplets too.
We got um, Dr. Stone. Uh huh. I sleep,
I sleep attack on Titan season two. I work basically.
I mean like it's how can you not man?
Like every episode is just like a like rollercoaster.
And like for a lot of people we can on this for like five plus years
journey. Right. It's it's and it's,
and it's one of the few ones where it feels like it's run its natural course and
it's actually, it's actually coming to an end. You know what I mean?
And you know, I,
I said in a tweet that I feel like this is like watching a classic being made
and I have no doubts that if like,
even if he doesn't like completely slam dunk the ending,
even if it's just an okay satisfying ending,
it's going to go down as long as it's not like the crummiest ending.
Imagine wait for it. Multi-verse predicted multinationals,
which I would like to think is not going to happen.
[inaudible] is there in the season? You just can't compete. No,
one's talking about anything and I'm just like,
there's so many bang is the season and like attack on Titan.
He's just taking over. Sure.
Cause I remember I was watching the last season of breaking bad as it was airing
week by week. I'm sure I watched other TV shows during that time.
I cannot tell you what I watched other than, than breaking bad.
Like it was like the highlight, right? Like it's what it takes up your,
your space and your hype for like, or for what's going to,
it's going to be 26 episodes, right? No, it's going to be 14. It's 14. Yeah.
So right now, now from what I've heard like this, this is,
this is me going off of whatever, a speculation, warning margarita.
So it's going to be 14 episodes, I think 14 or 15,
which doesn't take it up to the end of the Mongo.
Cause the end of the manga ends in April sample. Yeah.
I heard that April or may. I can't remember,
but it's confirmed that the Monga is going to be ending this late spring,
summer kind of time.
I thought they were trying to do like a Juul ending where it was going to be.
They both were like ending at the same time. I thought,
Oh we can animate originally. No, no like it was gonna, he was probably gonna,
I thought he meant maybe he was going to like tell them the studio, the ending.
So what's so with the confirmed amount of episodes, that's out so far,
what people are thinking is going to happen is either we're going to get a
season four part to or we are going to get a movie.
Oh I will. I'm speculating. It's going to be a mood thing.
I think a movie Cal successful demons. I know,
I know they get to see that Nick probably saw them, was like,
we can do that with the last attack on Titans thing.
Just saying honestly like if I'm up to speed, run the Hong go real quick.
[inaudible] Joey was saying, there's a type it out.
Please live translate for me. Come on. Yeah. I'll hire a professional light.
You know the ones that the governments, when they go to the meetings,
I'll hire them to get in the seat behind me in the theater.
All I get to say is like personal reasons.
I wish I hope it's going to be a movie just so I can be the first one to make a
video on it.
[inaudible] I'm going to go to the midnight screening and I'm going to make a
video and be like, yeah guys.
It was Epic that time where I would not do that. I'm kidding. I'm joking.
I wouldn't,
I would not ruin possibly one of the greatest animates to go down in history
just for YouTube click. But I'd be like, Hey guys, I think I know what happened.
I watched it all three times.
I think I got the gist of what's going on with maiden the best.
What the is the movie legit? We watched the meat and the best movie. We'd like,
obviously there's no subtitles. I'm pretty sure I understood what happened.
I'm pretty happy. I'm pretty sure I got it. I got the GS was like plot, plot,
questionable child pop plot. And then
I was just like, Oh Kevin, you didn't, you did a, you did a good joke.
Cause Kevin was sitting right next to him. This song is good, man.
It's like go into hall, questionable child hall music. Good.
Basically. But yeah, like I,
everyone said the meaning of this movie was amazing and I'm just like,
I had a good time. I still haven't seen it. Honestly. It's fine.
I mean, I'm not going to take the one
who understood half of what was being said. It was fine.